Lea está instalando azulejos en el piso de un baño.
Ella tiene azulejos grandes y chicos.
Los azulejos grandes tienen
un área de 5 pies cuadrados...
voy a subrayarlo con el mismo color y los chicos tienen un área de 2 pies cuadrados.
2 pies cuadrados...
El área total del piso es de 40 pies cuadrados.
Si "l" es el número de azulejos grandes usados
y "s" el número de azulejos chicos usados,
podemos escribir la siguiente ecuación, veamos
si hace sentido esta ecuación.
Aquí tenemos "l" el número de azulejos grandes
que multiplicamos por 5 pies, que es el área
que ocupa cada azulejo, así es que esta expresión
nos da el área que ocupan todos los azulejos grandes
y el área que ocupan los azulejos
chicos es "2s", 2 pies cuadrados por cada azulejo
por el número de azulejos chicos
y sabemos que el área total del piso es 40,
si sumamos el área cubierta por los azulejos chicos y el área cubierta por los azulejos grandes nos da 40.
Al sumar estas dos cosas nos da 40, esto hace sentido, estoy totalmente de acuerdo con la ecuación.
¿Y que nos piden?
¿Cuál de estas combinaciones de azulejos permite cubrir exactamente todo el piso del baño?
Así es que, cubrir exactamente todo el piso del baño.
Nos están aclarando que no quieren que cubramos
ni de más, ni de menos el piso del baño.
Por lo cual, para hacer esto, necesitamos
sustituir estos valores de azulejos
y ver si se verifica esta ecuación.
Empecemos con estos valores, nos dan 6 azulejos
grandes, "l" es 6, mientras que el número
de azulejos chicos "s" es igual a 5.
Verifiquemos si esta combinación cubre
exactamente el piso del baño,
sustituyamos los valores en la ecuación.
Tenemos entonces,
5 por "l" que es igual a 6
más 2 por "s" que es igual a 5...
2 por 5 y esto ¿a cuánto es igual?
Esto es igual a 5 por 6 = 30, más 2 por 5 = 10
y si se cumple la ecuación, 30 más
10 es igual a 40, así que esta primera si
cumple con la ecuación que tenemos aquí.
Veamos la segunda combinación,
parece que esto no va a cumplir, pues si en la primera
combinación teníamos 6 grandes y 5 chicos
y cubrió exactamente el piso, aquí tenemos
6 grandes y 6 chicos, no va a cumplir...
Pero, verifiquemos esto en la ecuación.
Esto nos da 5 por el número de azulejos grandes
que es 6, 5 por 6 azulejos grandes, "l" es igual a 6 más 2 por el número de azulejoschicos que es 6.
Y esto va a ser igual a 5 por 6 = 30,
más 2 por 6 = 12 y esto es 42,
que definitivamente esto es distinto de 40,
no cumple la ecuación.
Si nos hubieran pedido, que combinación alcanza
para cubrir el piso, entonces esta correndería,
pero como nos están pidiendo que lo cubra
exactamente, no voy a seleccionar esta opción.
Ahora, ¿qué pasa con 7 azulejos chicos y
5 azulejos grandes?
Este caso tampoco parece que va a funcionar,
porque aquí tenemos exactamente el mismo
número de azulejos chicos...
¡no! espérame, déjame corregir esto,
aquí invirtieron el orden, estos son azulejos grandes,
aquí hay 7 azulejos chicos y 5 azulejos grandes...
7 azulejos chicos y 5 azulejos grandes.
Veamos si esto funciona.
Tenemos 5 pies cuadrados de cada azulejo grande,
por el número de azulejos grandes que en
este caso son 5 azulejos grandes y a eso tenemos
que sumarle 2 pies cuadrados
por cada azulejo chico, que en este caso son 7 azulejos chicos.
Esto nos va a dar 5 por 5 = 25,
más 2 por 7 = 14, nos da 39,
39 es distinto de 40, así es que este caso no funciona.
Finalmente, 10 azulejos chicos y 4 azulejos grandes.
Veamos si funciona, para 4 azulejos grandes
tenemos 5 pies cuadrados por 4 azulejos grandes,
ese es el área que cubren los azulejos grandes
y a eso tenemos que sumarle 2 pies cuadrados
por cada azulejo chico, es decir, 2 por 10,
esto es lo que se cubre con azulejos chicos
y a eso se le suma lo que se cubre con azulejos
grandes, esto es igual a 20 más 20 que efectivamente
coincide con 40.
Así es que este caso también funciona.